[Music]
hello everyone
today we are going to start discussion
of this
extremely important problem of plate
with a circular hole
under uniaxial tensile loading in fact
this is one of the most
important problems in all of applied
elasticity and
to be sure we must emphasize
that it doesn't get any more applied
than this
the reason is in many many different uh
mechanical engineering situations you
will find
that the situation can very well be
modeled
either directly by this kind of a
problem situation
or some variant of it furthermore
[Music]
another variant of this problem which
does not actually involve
this type of a circular pull but an
elliptical hole
is actually the gateway to a completely
new branch of mechanics which is
referred to as
fracture mechanics but of course we
won't have the time and scope to go into
all of that
but it is extremely important point to
note that
uh that entire discussion of fracture
mechanics
has its uh has its groundwork sort of
uh in this uh problem okay
so with this uh motivation of addressing
this very very important problem let us
get down
to uh how we may address the solution of
this
so uh so we have this uh
apparently not very convenient looking
situation where uh even though the
geometry is very regular like we have
a rectangular plate it's a nice geometry
and within it very nicely there is a
circular hole but if you think about
uh how we may address this elasticity
problem
in terms of finding out the stresses
there does not seem to be a direct way
out
okay so suppose this hole were not
present then
this is a very very easy problem we have
all done this like it's a direct
application of a second degree
polynomial
but the presence of this hole makes it
a very challenging and very interesting
problem
so how do we address this all right so
we start off with the situation of
what we actually know okay so what we
know
is the solution to the very very simple
problem of
a rectangular plate which does not have
a hole so let's start with that point
suppose let's imagine that this hole is
really not present
what we'll do then so if the hole okay
so if the hole is not present
ah
so if let me just change the
pen style
so if the hole is not present
okay so we imagine such a situation if
the whole is not present
then the solution is easily given by
this kind
of an airstress function so phi is equal
to
s y squared
so what is s s is nothing but the
magnitude
of this uniaxial tensile loading okay so
we have s here as on this side it's
nicely balanced
and this y you please note is
simply
it's simply the
y axis like this so we have the
corresponding x
axis on this side
so this is our x and this is our y and
you may be thinking that we went
discussing to the elasticity under polar
coordinates why have you reverted back
to this x y system
so it's not like that so we'll soon be
uh converting this like in the very next
step we'll be converting this to the
polar coordinate system
so so if we do that okay so we know that
y is equal to
r sine theta in the corresponding polar
coordinate system
so this is absolutely equivalent to
s r square sine squared theta
all right now please note
that the motivation of writing it like
this is to actually
obtain the solution that sigma
xx is equal to del square
phi del y square is equal to
s okay and please note that in order to
get this thing adjusted i must put a
half here
because after the differentiation after
the first differentiation of phi with
respect to y
i'll get this twice out so that must
cancel with this half
and when i do the second differentiation
i'll ultimately obtain
s so sigma x x x is actually
s so all that is fine and please
let us not forget that this this we are
imagining under a situation where the
hole is not present so we have to
ultimately bring back the whole but that
is for later
for now for now what we are really
interested
in obtaining is uh
is after after convincing ourselves that
this kind of an error stress function
does actually give us the sigma xx we
know this very well
what are the forms of the corresponding
stresses or the stress components
in the polar coordinate system so what
are so what are the expressions of sigma
rr
sigma theta theta and sigma r theta
corresponding to this
half sr square sine squared theta
so let's get back to our jupiter
notebook and
see what those expressions are and that
those expressions will actually give us
some clue
as to how to address this problem of
plate with a circular hole okay and
please note
okay so this problem can actually be
solved by the way that we are going to
solve it
only and only if this kind of a circular
hole
is not too large okay it needs to be
very very small
okay so let's go to jupiter notebook and
find out the expressions of the
stress components in the polar
coordinate system
so i have already fired up a file here
so as usual we'll import our polar
utilities
everything from polar utilities
this will take a little moment all right
we are done now
so uh the first thing we
will set up is the symbol s
because that is the magnitude of the
applied tensile loading
with that out of our way we can actually
define our
air stress function in this fashion now
you please note
let's take a quick look back so you note
that this is phi is equal to half of
sy square now
we might be initially tempted to write
this
uh or to instruct a in
a codified form to write this as 0.5 or
1 by 2
sy squared but remember that we want
that we really want to do this
in as symbolic of fashion as possible
and there is a way
to to write this in a proper
proper rational
fraction kind of fashion by this way
okay so we won't write this as simply 1
by
2 or 0.5 rather we will define this half
like a proper
rational fraction and the way to do it
is by this command
sim dot rational one comma two so
suppose we wanted to write this as
uh one third then then we would simply
have to write the same dot rational one
comma three
and so on and so forth all right so
what you really want to write is half s
into r square into sine square theta
please note that i do not have to
specify or define the symbols r
and theta because those are already
defined in my polar utilities package
okay so if i want to
display my file i can do that in a nice
fashion
i just have to use the display
facilities from ipython
it involves a little bit of more typing
as we have seen many times earlier
but the end result is quite neat let's
do that
all right so that's that's how it is so
phi is equal to half of sr squared sine
squared theta
now corresponding to this what is the
sigma rr
so we use
these function definitions sigma
underscore rr
which is actually the function function
name
defined within the polarities package
similarly for sigma theta theta
and sigma r theta
and again we display this in a nice
fashion
and quickly copy paste the remaining two
to reduce the time involved in typing
that's my sigma theta theta finally for
sigma r theta
i have this
all right so these are my expressions so
sigma rr is equal to
s cos square theta sigma theta theta
is equal to s sine square theta and
sigma r theta
is equal to minus half of s sine to
theta
and we remind ourselves very importantly
again that
this the stress field that we have just
obtained
so
from this what we are obtaining sigma
rr is equal to
s cos square theta
sigma theta theta is equal to s
sine square theta and
sigma r theta is equal to
minus half of s sine to theta
minus half of
sine two theta
so this these stress components sigma r
r sigma theta theta and sigma
that we have obtained these pertain to
the problem
the very simple problem that we would
have if the
hole were not present but the whole
actually is present so we
we should be solving that problem and
not this simple problem
what can we do so for that uh
a very classical way of proceeding is in
this fashion
what we say is that let's say this hole
is very very small
okay so our method of proceeding will
work only if this
of the dam of the other the radius of
this hole is much smaller
compared to the dimensions of this
rectangular plate
okay now one might even say that we are
considering
a an an infinite plate a plate of
infinite dimensions
infinite of course uh in relation
relative
to the dimensions of this uh circular
hole
now because we have obtained this kind
of uh
of a stress field okay this stress field
will be true for
around a circle okay please note that we
have obtained this field
these stress components for this
rectangular plate
and still if you are considering the
situation without the hole
and we consider a circle all right
so we if we consider a circle like this
uh let me draw a circle
uh send because i'm imagining this
circle let me draw it in a
you know in a dashed with this dashed
border okay maybe
i'll use the white color itself
and i will place it
concentric with
the original circle circular hole okay
so what i'm imagining is this kind
of a circular border this imaginary
circular border
or just a circular uh just
which whose radius is much much larger
than this
uh this actual whole radius okay
so from this diagram it may be it may be
a bit
misleading because the radius of this
circle with the dashed border is
certainly not much much larger than this
whole radius but you imagine that such
is the case okay i don't want to be
drawing
this circular hole in the form of a
little dot here
again just to keep the the picturization
clearer
but uh what i'm going to say holds true
only if this this kind of a
this radius is much much larger than
this okay
so if this hole were not present
then all around the periphery of this
dash circle the very same stress fields
would be very much true
[Music]
all right so we need not consider
anymore this original rectangular plate
problem
rather we can consider just this kind
of a circle okay so if we just forget
about this rectangular plate
it doesn't do us any harm because we are
if you're still considering
uh this this circle with the dashed
border the sigma r r sigma theta theta
and sigma r theta
is very much true if remember that we
are still not considering the hole here
so if you sit at any point here we can
fit any point here we can still very
much
obtain those stress components it is
absolutely no problem
now uh
we have to ultimately pick bring back
this circular hole
so how do we do that okay
so in order to do that the
problem that we need to solve is
actually
this kind of a
circle with the hole inside it and now
it is starting to look somewhat familiar
to us from our previous solutions
okay so that's exactly what we are going
to do uh in the next page
so we draw this circle again
we draw our our imaginary circle
like this
let's make it reasonably big
and let us consider the actual
the real circular hole present inside it
so please accept the fact that these two
circles
are actually concentrate okay
so what i'm saying is that in order to
solve my actual problem
i i what i what i'm doing here is to
imagine this kind of the circular border
with the known press components around
it
and now i want to solve the problem
anywhere within this thing
okay of course at the end of it
all i have to be careful about
the dimensions that i am talking about
because that is embedded
within my uh within my understanding of
the problem
so what i need to do is something like
this what i need to do
is to consider a radius for this
for this for this outer
for this circle let's say that this
radius
is is b
and then the radius for this smaller
hole
i'll let that be a okay
so
let that be a
now on now i will not say anything about
the relative magnitude of b
or a but ultimately what i have to do is
to make this b
10 to infinity okay basically i want to
make b
much much larger than a so
what i'm basically doing here is this
i'm
i'm trying to solve a problem
uh where the boundary conditions
are like this maybe i write here um
okay so i'll write it here uh i'll leave
this space for something else
so the boundary conditions that i need
to
have for this problem so
sigma rr okay sigma rr
is equal to if we go back to the
previous page
you'll see that this is s cos square
theta
this is at r equal to b
sigma r theta is equal to
minus half s time
to theta
again at r equal to b
so we are writing basically the traction
components in the radial direction and
in the tangential direction
okay so when we are writing the sigma r
equal to sigma s cos square theta
we are actually writing the traction
component
in the radial direction we are writing
the boundary condition corresponding to
the traction component
in the in the tangential direction for
with this sigma r theta equal to minus
half
s sine to theta okay please note
that in the specification of these
boundary conditions
i do not need to involve the sigma theta
theta it simply does not come
about because the way the traction
boundary conditions emerge
but i am not done with the specification
of these boundary conditions
because i now have to respect the
presence of the whole
okay so this is the this is the part uh
let me write this clear clearly here
that
i am actually bringing back my whole
let me write that clearly here
and bring that box down a little bit
and
we are bringing back the hole
so sigma rr is equal to 0
at r equal to a so on this
inner periphery around this hole please
note that that is
completely attraction-free whole so
sigma r equal to zero at r equal to a
furthermore sigma r theta is equal to
zero
at r equal to a
so our original problem will be said to
have been solved if we can solve
the elasticity problem corresponding to
these boundary conditions
but only when we say that this b
is much much larger than a so i repeat
what i have basically done till now is
to
re-interpret or re-represent the
original
problem which was this plate with a
circular hole
by this easier looking
domain which consists of two concentric
circles but with the understanding
that the radius the outer radius here
must be much much larger than this a
only when only
then this strategy will work
and this problem will be said to have
been solved only when these boundary
conditions
only when the elasticity problem with
these boundary conditions
are solved okay so it boils down to this
that we have to choose an air stress
function
in such a way that the bound that the
stresses
emerging from those boundary con from
those from that air stress function
will be satisfied will be satisfying
these conditions
okay so the the way ahead seems
clean enough okay so we have reduced it
reduce the entire problem to
in to a known kind of framework
okay so we have an elasticity problem we
have boundary conditions all that you
have to
do is to select an appropriate stress
function and this is where we have to be
a little bit clever in how we approach
this problem
so you see
suppose okay suppose
[Music]
we had a situation that
the sigma r r here you forget about the
sigma r theta
okay let's consider the sigma r r the
sigma r
r is uh is is present here in the form
uh this boundary condition is form
represent in the form of
s cos square theta but suppose it was
it wasn't present in the form of an s
cos square theta suppose it was in the
form
of some constant value and if
it were in the form of a constant value
and
now suppose you forget about the sigma r
theta
then if you just look at the problem
sigma r r is something
is equal to something constant sigma r
theta is not there and sigma r equal to
0 at r equal to a
then that is very much reminiscent okay
we don't have that but i'm saying that
if we if we had that then that would be
very much reminiscent
of the pressure vessel kind of problem
that we have already done earlier
okay so that was one of the earliest
things that we did in the
uh while addressing uh or
demonstrating examples of the polar
coordinate system elasticity problems
okay so we we want to again re
rewrite this problem somehow in the form
of something
that we already know and that we can
actually do
if you think about it what we can do is
this sigma r equal to s
cos square theta again i will rewrite
this thing okay so there's a lot of
rewriting
and representations going on for this
problem and that's the how we proceed
that's how we proceed
always do things always convert things
in terms of what we know
so this s squared theta
that will convert so this cos square
theta can be written
as half of 1 plus cos to theta
all right now you see
this is made up of two parts one of them
is this constant part half of s the
other part
well unfortunately it is still dependent
on
theta you can't do anything about it
okay
but this gives us a clue what if
this original problem that we are doing
okay where of course you understand when
i say this
original problem i i actually mean that
this is basically a reworked version of
the real original problem which was the
plate with a circular hole
so this is like the the second hand
original problem and that second-hand
original problem i want to recast
in maybe in a third hand original
problem i can say that
such a word uh what i'll do is
i'll extract this part the half s part
okay and i will write these boundary
conditions
as two sets of boundary conditions let
me write that okay so these boundary
conditions i rewrite
as two sets of boundary conditions so
what we are going to do
ultimately in terms of the real
implementation is to solve
two different problems so for the
problem one
the problem one boundary conditions are
like this
sigma r r is equal to
half of s nothing else okay we we
sacrifice this
half s cos to theta we we don't really
sacrifice but we
sacrifice it for this problem one and we
and we separate out into a problem two
so sigma r equal to half s sigma r
theta as you can imagine we're going to
set this equal to zero
and of course this is at r equal to b
this also
is at r equal to b
sigma r r is equal to 0
at r equal to a so that remains
unchanged from this
from this problem and again sigma r
theta
is equal to 0 at
r equal to a so that is my problem 1
boundary condition
for the problem 2 because you note
that i must be having
these two problems set up in such a
fashion
that when i club them together i must
get back
these boundary conditions so all i have
to do
is adjust for the remaining terms so
half s is already taken care of
in order to get back to get back this s
cos square theta
all that i have to do is add to take
care of this
half of s cos 2 theta and that is
at r equal to b
next sigma theta theta is equal to
ah sorry sigma r theta
is equal to so that's that's where we
write this term
minus half s sine to theta
at r equal to b
and sigma
r r is equal to 0 at
r equal to a sigma
r theta is equal to 0 at
r equal to a so you see what we have
done here
overall okay so this is a quick summary
of what we have done
we started from this late in a circular
whole problem
first of all we imagine that the hole is
not present we
we arrived at some notion of the stress
field which is present
far away from this hole okay so
far away from this whole means as if the
hole is not present
and that can be represented or that can
be thought of to be
to be the stress components present all
around this kind of a
circular boundary
and because we can think of it like that
we actually forget the original problem
and recast it in this problem in the
form of this problem
where this is a large domain large
circular domain within which there is a
concentric hole
and all over this boundary we have the
same boundary
same stress components present as the
boundary conditions
the same stress components that we found
on the first page has the
boundary conditions here and where
we now respect that around the whole
there is the traction preconditions
given by this sigma r equal to zero
and sigma r theta equal to zero now we
would
have very much have like to solve this
problem directly
except that these boundary conditions
are not very convenient
so we take we go go an extra step and
decompose this problem itself
furthermore or once more into two
problems
problem one with these boundary
conditions so where the sigma r
is very much a constant and this is
almost
like this is a this is a ready-made
thing for us already because we know the
pressure vessel problem
solution uh we just have to replicate
that
and somewhat of a new problem
where the sigma rr is having this kind
of a form and the sigma r theta
is having this kind of a form all right
now uh the challenge
the whole challenge of this problem
ultimately boils down
to finding a a form of the area stress
function
which will actually give us this
particular
form of sigma rr and this particular
form
of sigma r theta okay
so how do we go about doing that well
for that a little experience is
necessary or you can go
and try a little bit of trial and error
but uh it has been found already for us
that if we take the form
of i okay let us call this phi
2 because let us reserve this phi
1 for this problem the phi 2 will be for
this problem
and that phi to form
it will be
like gr cos to theta
where this gr is some
function which is purely
dependent on r and that is multiplied by
this
cos 2 theta term okay and you will
find out that if we start out with this
particular form
then sigma r will come out in this
fashion with a cos to theta dependence
and the sigma r theta will come out with
a sine to the
sine two theta dependence now now
what i really want you to do is to
address
this problem this problem one and this
problem two
starting on with this uh form of phi two
you already know what the form of phi
one should be
uh to start out with this form of phi
two find out the solution corresponding
to this
with these boundary conditions satisfied
club them together ultimately what you
get with this phi
1 and take the limit that b
tends to infinity okay so when you do
that
and you do that all of these things in
jupyter notebook you will arrive
at the final solution so uh
i think so this is like a combined
uh lecture uh problem uh
exercise for you uh i will be providing
the link
to the entire solved uh
problem with this phi 1 and phi 2
and the entire solution given even with
the limits of
the limit b tending to infinity taken
but i urge all of you
to try this on your own i mean the the
the amount of satisfaction that you will
derive by doing this on your own is
simply
uh i mean you have to feel that that
satisfaction of having doing it yourself
okay but nevertheless i will be
providing the link to the solution
in the description below all right so
with this i end this
lecture thank you very much